hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to the chess draft 14.
now as per the many requests i like to
show you a nice trap against the slough
defense
after the move d4 d5 and c4
there are two popular response from the
black perspective one is the move e6
that is known as queen's gambit decline
and the second is c6 which is known as
slow defense in recent times slow
defense getting very very popular the
simple reason is
black position is very very solid in the
opening and the second important point
is there is hardly any trap exist
for the white perspective
but we can consider this as a bonus
because
when you are going to play this trap
you will find many slav opponents off
guard
here i propose that y should continue
with the move knight to f3
and if black responds with the move e6
then it goes to the another opening that
is known as a semi slow which we are not
going to cover over here we are only
going to cover the main line of the slaw
defense which start with the move knight
to f6
after the move knight to f6 i like to
propose another odd looking move that is
the move e3
at first side it looks very stupid
because this limit the activity of this
dark square bishop
but we'll see in a minute what is the
idea behind it
so after the move e3 the proper slow
defense move is bishop to f5
and it looks very very logical because
what black wants to do is now to play
the move e6 then combined with the moves
such as knight b to d7 and bishop to e7
castle on the king side and you can
already see black will have a wonderful
position
now the important thing over here is
when black played the move bishop to f5
only now white is going to capture the d
phone
the most usual response is c captures d5
if black capture with the piece then
later stage white can always look
forward to push the e4 and that way
white will gain the center and gain the
initiative so the most frequent response
is c captures b5 and after this y should
continue with the move knight to c3
the main line goes with the move e6
please note that queen to b3 is not at
all dangerous because black can always
respond with the move queen to b6
and although black pawn will be double
on the b file
black get the open a file and that is
enough compensation
now here the third time i'm going to
propose you a odd move that is knight to
e5
and this is the starting position of our
chest strap
because as per the slav theory
many people i found that
automatically play either knight to c6
or knight b to d7 or even the move a6
which is a complete blunder
the main move here i suggested is bishop
to d6 or knight f to d7 however white
will still get a slight h
but
especially in the rapid game or the
blitz game you are not going to see
those moves you're often going to see
this move that is
knight b to d7
and if you open and play this move
he give you the full point
i give you a few seconds can you find
what is what is wrong with this move
i hope you find this move that is the
move g4
and black is in a big big danger
let's see how
now the first question we need to ask is
what is wrong if black captured the
knight that is
knight captures e5 and after d captures
e5
black take the g4 pawn so we'll take two
possibilities in the first one black
take the g4 pawn with the bishop so
bishop captures g4
after this white will simply play the
move
bishop to b5 check
and now black in a big big danger queen
to d7 looks very hopeless so the obvious
looking move is
either knight to d7
or king to e7 so let's look each by turn
if knight to d7 then the simplest is the
protection of that bishop is gone so now
i can simply capture this bishop
and if king comes up so king to e7
then the simplest is pawn captures
knight with a check so black has to
recapture the pawn
and then what is going to capture the
bishop so that way materially white is
too pissed
so it is very obvious that
bishop captures g4 is prohibited
you might ask what's wrong in knight
captures g4 so black come out from the
all the thread
but here
we have the another finishing blow that
will more or less finish the game
i give a few seconds can you find the
right continuation
i hope you find this one that is queen
to a4 jack
now king has to move because queen
cannot come to the d7 square
the simple reason is bishop will go to
the fire and black will lose a queen
so that means queen has to come to the
e7
after king to e7
white has this sneaky move that more or
less finished the black off and that is
the move queen to b4 check now if king
goes back to the e8 then bishop to b5 is
a very very deadly that means black will
surely lose a queen
so king has to go to the d7 square after
this the simplest is queen captures b7
and once again if the king goes to the
e8 then bishop to b5 is very very strong
so the only move left is queen to c7
after this white will continue with the
move bishop to b5 check and when black
plays the move king to it white will
simply capture the rook and still there
is a mating threat exist so the only
move left is
queen to c8 because if your opponent
plays king to e7 then queen to e8 is a
checkmate so the very obvious is queen
has to come in between
and now white has a choice either to
capture the queen and go into the end
game where white is a clear p clear rook
up
and
if white is feeling aggressive then
white can even capture the a7 pawn
and go for the attack
so we come to the conclusion that knight
captures e5 is actually a blunder
so that means that bishop has to move
if black plays moves such as bishop to
e4 then that is very hopeless because
white can simply play the move f3 and
not only that bishop has to move but now
the g4 pawn has been protected
so very obvious move over here is bishop
to g6
after this white will continue with the
move h4
so now what is threatening the move h5
which black needs to pay attention
once again at this point knight captures
e5 is not possible because the simplest
move is d captures e5 and once that
knight moves then h5 will nab the piece
forever
so the most usual response from the
black perspective is either the move h5
or h6
and they will leads to the same result
now i like to show you the picture of
the person who has invented this trap
his name
is bogulubo he played two world
championship match against the alakan
and during his time he defeated
many slav defense players
in this game his opponent responded with
the move h6
while continuing with the move knight
captures g6 and after f captures g6
bogulabo continue with the move bishop
to d3 so attacking the g6 the only
response is king to f7 and now comes the
whole idea that is queen to c2
so now there is no way black can defend
this pawn
so his opponent decided that he will
grab the g4 pawn and that way
probably he will be materially up white
continue with the move bishop captures
g6 and after king to g8
you might think okay black is
temporarily disturbed with his king
but now comes the another dazzling move
that is
knight captures d5
and black position is completely ruined
in this game his opponent responded with
capturing the piece
and white responded with the move queen
to f5 now there are four different
threats three of them are leading to the
checkmate
and another one is taking back the piece
so very obvious is black need to defend
the checkmate threat so his opponent
responded with the move first of all
bishop jack and after king to e2 he
defended the mate with the move queen to
f6
but now white get the piece back and
after the following sequence that is
let's say
knight to f8 bishop to d3
knight to e6 so idea is to play rook to
f8 and creating some pressure on the f2
square
but just one move and his opponent
resign that is queen to f5
so now black is forced to exchange the
queen and after the queen trade white
has this lovely bishop pair and not only
that white is a clear form of
now i must admit that i myself is a slow
defense player and i fall into this trap
in one of my game
so i like to show you that game as well
at this position instead of knight to d7
i responded with the move a6 and as i
have already mentioned that
whether black plays nc6 or nd7 or a6
it's all leads to this wonderful trap
and here my opponent responded with the
move g4
so after long thinking i played the move
bishop to g6 and he responded with the
move h4
here i was very shocked by this king
side attack so i responded with very
nature looking move at six
but now comes knight captures g6 and
after f captures g6
familiar thing bishop to d3 and king to
f7
here my opponent showed the another good
move which white can also play in this
position that is
queen to f3 so now the threat is very
simple white wants to play the move g5
and capture the knight
i responded with the move bishop to d6
and here my opponent played the move g5
here i thought that he cannot have this
piece so i captured the pawn and and
when he recaptured i capture his rook
obviously white need to capture this
rook and now i put my knight e8 square
here i continue with the move queen to
f3
so i start running with my king so i
played keen to e7 and now he played a
obvious looking move that is bishop
captures g6
i responded with the move
king to d7 so i want to
park my king on the queen side where
there are many pieces so i can shelter
my king
but my opponent said that i don't have
time for that so he responded very
energetically and he played the move e4
opening up the center at the right time
i desperately do not want my center to
be open so i captured the pawn and he
recaptured with the queen and now
i want to finish my queen side piece
development so i played the move knight
to c6
but once again
this moves
creates many weaknesses and he played
the obvious move that is d5
and i must admit that at this point i
was already feeling the pressure so i
obviously captured this pawn
and when white recapture with the knight
i played the move knight to e7 hoping
that white captured the knight so i can
play capture with the queen and exchange
the queens
but nope he played the accurate move
that is bishop to f5 check
and after knight captures and queen
captures
i thought that my king will be safe now
after king to c6
but after bishop to e3
i realized that my position is
completely hopeless
last but not least i desperately try for
counter with the move queen to if i
check
but after king to f1
i realized that even i cannot take the
knight because rook check and i'll lose
my queen
in the time trouble i finally played the
move
b5
but here my opponent finishment style so
he played the move rook to steven check
and after king to b7 he played this
queen check and there is no stopping and
in fact i lost on time at this point
so this is one wonderful trap existence
loud defense
if you are a d4 player and if you are
very annoyed by the slow defense this
one trap you might want to try out in
your game
well good luck for trying in your own
game
please feel free to comment and like on
this video i'll meet you soon bye